hi i'm andrew garfield and this is the
wired auto complete interview good luck
[Music]
never in my life have i googled myself
of course i have it mostly hurts to
google yourself so i wouldn't recommend
it
fun
is andrew garfield a nice guy you you
decide man you decide i don't know you
tell me am i a nice guy sometimes like
if i'm walking down the street i'm
having a nice day and you say yo and i'm
like yo that's nice but then sometimes
i'd be like i don't want to say yo i'm
tired or like something just happened
that made me sad i just want to be a
person man so yeah yes and no is andrew
garfield in uptown funk i wish sandra
garfield playing spider-man again
oh you almost got me no no no i'm not
i'm not i'm not
crying out loud
but i'm excited to see what they're
going to do with the next movie because
i i just love them
is andrew garfield alive what do you
think what do you see
what do you feel what is andrew
garfield's accent this one it's an
english one i was born in los angeles
but i was raised in england south of
england specifically banstead surrey
sm71dy is my postcode or was what was
andrew garfield's first movie lions for
lambs a ridiculous first movie to do
because robert redford was directing and
starring next on the call sheet was
meryl streep and then after meryl streep
was thomas cruz and then after that it
was this little child called andrew
garfield that had never made a film
before and that's ridiculous what was
andrew garfield nominated for
an oscar that is bad grammar but that's
fine because it's a search engine it
doesn't have any feelings although maybe
the people that created the search
engine should have to think about that i
was nominated for an oscar for a film
called hacksaw ridge i played a
character called desmond dos he was a
conscientious objector in world war ii
in okinawa and it's a true story and he
he he rescued the lives of 75 people off
of this death defying battlefield ridge
and lowered them down on a rope it's
superhuman i remember on day one of the
battle scenes of that i thought i'm
gonna do all this for real i'm gonna
drag these guys to the end i'm gonna let
them down after the first guy i
literally had i had to lay down for two
hours like it is ridiculous how this guy
did it was absolutely insane and he was
he was built
he was as you know you know skinnier
than me what harry potter movie is
andrew garfield in
i don't know pretty sure none i'm
flattered to be considered a marauder a
fan cast if you will of a young remus
lupin in the marauders that's a sweet
thought and i appreciate um your
consideration what does andrew garfield
think of tom holland i really like him i
think he's a wonderful person i met him
once at the baftas one year with a
lovely talk he's very sweet he's a
kingston boy with neighbors pretty much
he's from surrey and then you know as a
as an actor i just think he's absolutely
wonderful i'm just super grateful that
he's the one filling out the suit i love
those films i think they've just done an
incredible incredible job with it
does andrew garfield does andrew
garfield sing and take boom so andrew
garfield does sing and tick tick boom
yes thank you i worked very very closely
with an amazing vocal coach liz kaplan
and all of lima well miranda's amazing
musical direction team they enabled me
to open my voice up to the point where i
could honor jon's songs and feel
confident enough to belt them out as he
always did when he was doing his one-man
show and otherwise so it was a privilege
to be able to learn a skill that i've
always wanted to attain and do it in
service to john larson does andrew
garfield have social media no officially
no i have a couple of creeper accounts
just to follow news you know but no i
i'm far too sensitive to do it myself
does andrew garfield know how to skate
skateboard yeah i used to skateboard
when i was a kid that was my first real
love actually when i was 13 14 15
listening to rage against the machine
the beastie boys with
trousers far too big for me with my butt
hanging out my big claim to
skateboarding fame for anyone who knows
about that famous skate sport on the
south bank of london there's a set of
seven steps and i once kick flipped that
set of seven when i was 15 years old and
then i broke my wrist dropping him for
the first time on a vert ramp does
andrew garfield like lasagna i get the
reference and i don't appreciate it
[Laughter]
no i love garfield i used to love
reading garfield comics and i do love
lasagna but it's not related to the cat
but you know having that as a reference
is good because sometimes when people
ask what my name is for a reservation
for a restaurant or something and i have
an accent that's british and when i'm in
america a lot of the time people are
like huh and i'm like oh garfield like
the cat and like oh like the cat cute
and i'm like yeah it is cute
why andrew garfield don't ask me that
because i will talk for hours and i will
fall into an existential funk and i will
find my way through it and i will
realize the meaning of life but i won't
be able to express it and it will be a
whole waste of time for you but not for
me so i don't want to subject you to
that where is andrew garfield i'm
searching i'm always searching i'm
always trying to figure that out what is
andrew garfield what is he
what is andrew garfield's phone number
wait
i want to follow that bad grammar if i
put an apostrophe there what is andrew
garfield's phone number come on andrew
garfield organ movie
it sounds like the title of like my my
sex tape or something it's like a bad
translation of like what my sex tape
would be called it's been translated
from like another language and it's like
been printed on a t-shirt and you're
going for an organ movie i think you're
referencing never let me go
which is not a sex tape and far from it
and switching streams here it's just an
amazing story and i i would love for you
guys to watch the film andrew garfield
on neck it's true i'm not going to
debate that it's a reality i notice it
every day i look in the mirror and i'm
like oh there you are you're long neck
bastard and you go from justin
timberlake impression i did that on snl
i don't know if he enjoyed it i i wish i
could be justin when i was a kid i
wanted to be able to dance and sing like
him and she brought sexy back that is no
mean feat for one person to do i love
justin i loved working with him and the
social network and you know i had to
kind of keep my cool because you know i
am such a fan he was so supportive of me
during all that filming he was just such
a supportive dude like especially during
that laptop smashing scene he came up to
me afterwards and he just see i won't
say what he said to me but he was just
so lovely and it was like i'm gonna
remember this moment i'm talking about
it now i'm gonna remember this moment
forever because you're you're someone
who i so admire as an artist and like
the fact that like i grew up listening
to your music and now you're telling
you're telling me i did a good job on
something it's like damn that's really
special this is those are the special
moments i hope i never take for granted
andrew garfield ryan reynolds oh i think
this is a reference to the kiss the
golden globes kiss
this is a really fun moment i said to
him if you win kiss me instead of blake
your wife because blake's on the other
side and he was like amazing
let's do it and then he was like what if
even if i don't win i'm like yeah let's
just kiss so yeah that was fun it was
nice to do it
i liked it yes he did get lost in my
eyes i felt it and then i realized that
what what we had done was a mistake
because for me it was just a prank like
a fun thing but obviously you know it's
just happened to me before where people
catch feelings and i don't how tall is
andrew garfield's feet in
it's
is it size 10 how to get andrew garfield
hair
propecia i'm just kidding how did andrew
garfield became famous i don't believe i
am famous how old was andrew garfield
and doctor who young a little whipper
snapper 22 23. how long was andrew
garfield president says john garf john
garfield no who was the president james
garfield john garfield was a great actor
james garfield i was never president
what did andrew garfield win a tony for
angels in america i played the character
prior walter in the masterpiece that is
angels in america by tony kushner does
andrew garfield do his own stunts when
they allow me now that i'm a bit older
my knees are a bit creaky it's a tricky
thing but yeah i love it especially with
the spider-man stuff i loved it it was
my favorite part of that i used to be a
gymnast when i was a kid and i it was
like part of what made me love the
character so much and yeah it's so fun
so fun how many andrew garfield movies
are there i have no idea not many i
haven't made many movies comparatively
to other people because uh i'm a picky
son of a gun i'm either called to a film
or i'm not and tikti boom is one of
those rare ones where i feel very very
cold to it andrew garfield lima will
miranda tick tick booms in theaters now
netflix soon too have a good time with
it i think you will
i'm gonna go and now contemplate why
andrew garfield thanks so much wyatt
no thanks so much wyatt thank you thank
you